first you need to know a little bit
about what happened before a burning man
came into being its roots lie in the
1960s and 70s bohemian culture of San
Francisco in San Francisco in the 1980s
I was a member of a kind of social club
called the cacophony Society each month
various members got together and did
events which were often odd unusual and
challenging cacophony drew from
eccentric European traditions that
preceded us like the dhatus the
surrealist and the Situationist other
local influences were sancisco
culture jammers like the beats the Merry
Pranksters the diggers and an
underground cacophony precursor called
The Suicide Club we had an open
membership and made sure we were not
underground our motto was a randomly
gathered network of free spirits United
in the pursuit of experiences beyond the
pale of mainstream society you may
already be a member
cacophony devout numerous traditions
that made its events remarkable everyone
was included you had permission to be or
try anything events needed to be free
you took responsibility for your actions
you left places cleaner than when you
found them we use fake names and long
before smartphones it was be here now do
aah Krissy if you have a great idea you
do it everyone is a participant there
were no spectators political and
religious propaganda was unwelcome which
goes back to including everyone these
are some of the things that could
koppány later gave to Burning Man and so
we enter the first age the age of
exploration let's see how it unfolded
1986 a guy named Larry Harvey called his
friend Jerry James and said hey let's
build a man and burn him on the beach
Larry Harvey and Jerry James best
friends Larry a dreamer and Jerry a
carpenter built an 8-foot high wooden
figure resembling a man and burn it on
the beach for the summer solstice it's
little more than a family picnic
Larry and Gerry each brought their young
boys their ex-wives and the roommates
and the boys fashioned a wooden dog to
accompany the man not sure how to make a
fire they doused the figure with
gasoline and light it which goes up like
a second Sun strangers come running from
everywhere down the beach which creates
a party around it very excited by the
response decides to do it again the next
year but bigger of course and so they
did the second time they made more of an
effort to invite people was this flyer
Jerry James the carpenter help Larry
build a man that was a little taller
about 15 feet it was a small affair
maybe 20 or 30 people but they had a
tradition on their hands then in 1988 I
heard about some people who were going
to burn a wooden man on Baker Beach on
the Solstice I assume there were pagans
or something but it sounded fun so a
friend and I went down to the beach but
there were no pagans it was Larry Harvey
and Jerry James collaborating on this
very Dada anti art project of creation
and destruction at 30 feet their third
man was twice as tall and more complex
the arms were made to pivot by pulling
on a rope after he stood erect it was
all very interesting after that I kept
in touch with him since I was a
principal editor the cacophony Society
newsletter I decided I would list next
year's event in a future issue of the
newsletter which was perpetually titled
rough draft when the cacophony Society
saw the event listed in our June of 89
newsletter the number of attendees
quadrupled word-of-mouth became the
printed page and cacophony came out and
forced and pitched in to help with
logistics communication and construction
by now the man had become 40 feet tall
the height it would remain for the next
two decades it took several pickup
trucks to haul the parts to the beach
participation is high in these first
years with lots of hands to sneak the
parts down to the
Beach before the authorities could
notice by 1990 we were showing up on the
beach with 350 people but by then many
of these people were not friends or
friends of friends we had a four-story
tall wooden man and more uninvested
spectators as darkness approached we
prepared to erect the man but this time
the authorities arrived before we could
strike a match you can't do this here
where's your permit here Jerry James and
Larry Harvey discussed the matter was an
apprehensive crewman who member looks on
after much negotiation we convinced the
authorities that we would erect the man
but not burn it the crowd many of whom
were drunken has simply come for the
spectacle were not happy amid cries of
burn it anyway
Larry realized that the event was not
the same anymore it was too easy to show
up and have an opinion it was now
attracting the wrong people but even
with an angry crowd we kept our word we
had a party around the man but we did
not burn it on the beach that night and
it turned out okay because we heard
about a place far out in Nevada where we
could burn a giant wood man
[Music]
you